forget about your fancy sound system
with this little device you can play
music through just about any object you
connect it to any box or any anything
you want and you can prove from the
surface into a real speaker microwave
radiators umbrellas also work or even
trash cans anything you want made by
French company AV concept the speaker
uses a vibration system inspired by the
very same technology that submarines use
to communicate and thanks to a Bluetooth
connection you can control it with your
smart phone priced at 35 euros the
company's already sold about 50,000 of
them mostly in France that it wants to
start exporting as soon as this year no
we really want to go abroad to go with
the United States and Canada the French
companies developing accessories to like
this band lets you add a speaker on your
head you can connect it to your helmet
and then you have a sweet round at 60
degrees sound around your head so what
is really better about this is that you
can actually hear what is happening
outside there are more accessories on
the way the sound will just depend on
how creative you are